[Music]
and another one news submitted by
Scamander another way a businessman
tried to hire a hit man to take out his
rival but things didn't go as planned
is this a Chinese one yes happens like
every month I swear to god no but this
one's like a pyramid scam of hitman
brothers via Cohen's Cohen okay this is
like a college movie Oh sick I'm ready
Coen Brothers movie okay so I don't like
the home brother did you like burnt
after video that was good no I hated the
end you don't like the whole like how
something oopsy-daisy happens and that
grows in this manner [ __ ] man it's not
my [ __ ] but I respect y'all like she
doesn't like watching movies about
losers sure they are Joe what the [ __ ] I
feel like I'm like naked right now you
keep like revealing hope and [ __ ] but
that not make sense I don't know I never
thought about it I like how you paired
these two necklaces together well that's
good luck that's my cue
what was the most Joe thing you've ever
said this is the loopy hour we've been
doing this all what happened real urban
no real rules against I'll tell you
later if he remembers so six years ago
this dude named tan who's a real estate
company owner in China decided to hire a
hitman to eliminate a local competitor
whose surname is way way way yes who had
filed a civil court case against his
enterprises so tan was willing to pay a
total of 2 million yuan which is about
two hundred and eighty two thousand
dollars to have way taken out so he
contacted the services of a man named
Shi Huang gun to get the job done
but that's when she decided that it was
easier to subcontract yep the job to
someone else so he wouldn't do the dirty
deed himself and it's amazing he would
pay them half of the two million dollar
fee and just ask the client for more
money so he passed the job over to this
man named Mose
Chang Ching along with 1 million yuan
which is about one hundred forty-one
thousand dollars so and then he ended up
going back to ten to ask for another 1
million so the businessman agreed but
only if he could get proof that the guy
had been killed so that's when mo shan
ching the kool moe moe okay moe
he ended up subcontracting to another
man named yang pyramids dabba [ __ ]
murder next movie right here this
[ __ ] Tiger bed he ended up offering
him two hundred and seventy thousand
yuan up front and an extra five hundred
thousand yuan after the job was
completed but then same thing contracted
it I love how like they're probably all
not even assassins they're just like
would you kill him yeah well and then
they I don't know how to do this I'm
gonna ask this guy to do it so the yang
ended up getting this other man
subcontracting to Ling for a hundred
thousand you know young whirlwind oh no
that's really good and then this all
this ends with the homeless guy getting
31 for the bald on I'll get that
so then read this right no I swear so
now yeah a hundred thousand and then but
then by that point Ling decided that it
wasn't worth the effort so it just made
more sense to him to go and tell the
victim to fake his own death that wily
that way we get paid exactly what I
would have done that if I was painting
this yeah but then obviously the victims
ended up going to the cops instead of
faking his own death and that's how like
they racing it by a game all the way to
those who the victim would have had
money if the victim had taken posed dead
shots and then they had they had set
those back to the guy in the guys
okay this is confirmed then then it
would have Ingrid so wait so [ __ ] the
last guy Ling he didn't want to give the
dude money he was just like hey I'm
supposed to kill you but let me just
take a picture in you live they didn't
mention about giving the victim any
money they just mentioned that he was
just well what are you gonna cut a man
no what are you we're gonna cop how much
money they splitting at the end a
hundred thousand hey it's more than what
you had in the beginning
fourteen thousand dollars I'm town the
Chinese journalist made a diagram to
show shut the [ __ ] up we did it bro yeah
this is what I would have done if I made
a movie so the guy and he fakes you kids
up does faking his own death and because
he faked his own death he has to flee
right so he goes to like some tropical
place to go relax everyone moves up the
chain and gets paid cuz everyone thinks
that this guy really died this guy is so
happy that he killed his competitor he
goes on vacation to relax only to find
that guy they're really good now and
then they fall in love in paradise go
back get all this money back into all
these [ __ ] killers didn't didn't kill
and then she still has to kill they're
still bad I don't know it's three we got
to write that [ __ ] I don't know but in
your movie they're sucking each other
dude that's a dope idea yeah doesn't
need to be doesn't need to be
contractors this is my sane Buddha yeah
we know they're killers dude they look
hello not killers that's why they can't
I feel like the only had one sighs for
all of them they're all just lazy guys
who just wanted to cut I love how
foreign like cop shade or whatever they
have to have like a thousand guys in
uniform like
pay attention to that this always
happens like whenever someone gets
caught in like Japan or whatever they
have like 30 cops like marching down and
bring them because the chief cop was
like all right this is your job you got
to find them and then that guy was like
you know what hey this is your job you
gotta find him then he went to someone
else this is your jobs they're doing the
same thing dude that's like in LA I'm
like what are you 13 eat 30 [ __ ] cop
cars to go over this liquor store
robbery what's with that I think it's
just one guy no one else is nosy yeah
but yeah so then in Chinese courts
he wasn't even know each other yeah
that's how he is quarter oh this will
happen back in April of 2014 but it's
just recently now they've issued the
punishment even the courts subcontracted
to each other business in China they're
like I don't want to do the work yeah
you do it so I'm just gonna be middleman
that's smart though tan who started it
all about five years in prison she got
three years in six months both Yang's
got three years and three months mo
three years Ling two years old a very
little about its lesson that's two
sentences all the way down the chain
wait did it get time served
have they been serving time so or I'm
assuming that's like almost out now
that's that's right I don't know cuz it
has been five years yeah I mean they
didn't really commit a crime or kill
they just made a deal right so is it
really murderous well that's like I mean
in America at least attempted inspiring
you're conspiring that's well it's too
many syllables for him but yeah but my
story where they end up sucking each
other off is called to come spiring come
on we're back on it right we're back on
that's a nice necklace thirty big gun
bro stop thank you
not really that's not her kind of pond
okay fine but she loves puns is my point
but she doesn't really do dirty funds as
much just saying it just trying to be
accurate it looks good puns got it
come spine is great no come sparring is
like an 80s porn title that that that
got pitched in a room and they all said
now maybe yourself man breathing yeah
this guy's firing on spire he's like
that what is it
go make it prove us wrong oh no I can't
okay contacts he brought a notebook to
write jokes out yeah
interviewed the guy that was supposed to
get killed like that he'd go like oh all
these people try to kill me and they're
all in jail that's awesome all right
well he's the one that ended up going to
the cops
well did they interview the first guy
then alright the one that was supposed
to do it that crime but like is he proud
yet where he's like who I started the
chain I don't know sounds like just a
Herbalife scam it's like you know why
did the boys the motive to kill the
first Gator because that is the civil
civil court case against his enterprises
yeah like coke wants to kill the Pepsi
guy dude that is some crazy [ __ ] though
how how frequent do you think
assassinations go down in like business
world China or even in America America
bro it's like all the time yeah you know
and then they're always like make it
look like a suicide
[Music]
wrong black ops [ __ ] dude I think yeah
or even like the whole like the Clinton
list that they have yeah I couldn't
commit body count like 30 how many
people are there like 30-yard tons
I'm lost what's his Clinton body how
many people like we think about Lewinsky
and then there's a girl account of
people that have been really really
close to the Clinton family like Bill
Clinton and Hillary and people and with
things that are getting this close to
leaked the not them they'd these guys
just died suicide or like just random
random yeah
yeah yeah and it's a huge [ __ ] list
so let's do actually thinks that so
Kennedy got killed by Oswald right and
then the guy who shot Oswald Jack Ruby
yeah he gets killed like does anyone
[ __ ] buy all this [ __ ] oh you think
it's Clinton still no I think it's
Clinton's dad or mom yeah obviously
come on rather their babies had to
protect their kids though in the future
yeah
people that go oh I stopped with Oswald
or stop with Ruby like do your [ __ ]
crazy right
but then who called the shots then like
who is the ring with that's our theater
you don't nobody knows that's the day
that we don't know yeah Illuminati yeah
that's that thing mm-hmm
so I'm assuming you guys are super into
like conspiracies ins no we think that
they're all [ __ ] yeah can see you
can't really person into a whole
conspiracy had one foot in he's just I'm
just checking out the temperature of the
water sometimes though like does he know
what he's doing but then I hang out with
them all enough and I'm like no
[Laughter]
[Music]